[Música]
el oficialismo en Argentina tendrá
candidato único a las elecciones
presidenciales de octubre el ministro de
economía Sergio massa fue confirmado por
la coalición unión por la patria como su
representante Agustín Rossi actual jefe
del gabinete del gobierno Será su
compañero de Fórmula conectamos con
Buenos Aires
cerraron las campañas en Guatemala de
Cara a las elecciones presidenciales del
domingo 22 candidatos se disputará en el
principal cargo político del país Aunque
tres avanzan con posibilidades de pasar
a una segunda vuelta
la Corte Suprema de Estados Unidos
rechazó por ocho votos a uno la
impugnación de dos Fiscales generales
republicanos a la nueva política de
deportación del gobierno de Joe biden la
ley Busca dar prioridad de deportación a
los migrantes detenidos en la frontera o
que representan amenaza la seguridad
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano mi
nombre Rodrigo sedano y es un placer
estar con ustedes abrimos el Informativo
en Argentina porque allí el oficialismo
tiene fórmula presidencial de unidad el
ministro de economía del gobierno de
Alberto Fernández Sergio massa será el
candidato de la coalición unión por la
patria lo acompañará en la aspiración en
la actual jefe de gabinete Agustín Rossi
anteriormente nuestro corresponsal en
Buenos Aires natalio cosoy nos comentaba
más detalles de este sorpresivo anuncio
Así es vaya sorpresa
hasta hoy
y el momento de este viernes en que se
conoció este anuncio los candidatos que
iban a competir dentro de Unión por la
patria que es la coalición oficialista
eran Eduardo guado de Pedro ministro del
interior y
Daniel y el embajador en Brasil y ellos
eran las personas que iban a disputar la
posibilidad de competir por la
presidencia en las primarias de agosto
de este año sin embargo apareció esta
noticia hace muy pocas horas y cuando se
acerca el cierre de la inscripción de
los candidatos que será este sábado a
medianoche y esto cambia el escenario
seguramente también llovió a estos dos
precandidatos que estaban avanzando con
su precandidatura de forma muy fuerte de
hecho Eduardo de Pedro había sacado un
video en el que se presentaba como
candidato a la presidencia Daniel que no
se iba a bajar de su precandidatura pero
nos encontramos con este anuncio de
unidad y había cierta sospecha de que
algo no estaba del todo cerrado por un
lado en el hecho de que no había salido
ningún anuncio oficial de Unión por la
patria y porque no había habido ningún
ninguna alocución ni ninguna observación
invención por parte de Cristina
Fernández de kirchner que es la
principal miembro de esta coalición de
la unión por la patria pero hoy salió el
anuncio oficial diciendo que será Sergio
manza el precandidato presidencial del
oficialismo Guatemala dio por terminada
la campaña electoral de Cara a las
elecciones presidenciales de este
domingo los tres principales candidatos
cerraron sus campañas en tres puntos
separados de la capital ciudad de
Guatemala entre los 22 candidatos se
destacan la ex primera dama Sandra
Torres el ex diplomático edmon mulet y
zuri Rio Sosa la hija del dictador
golpista acusado de genocidio indígena
Efraín ríos montt los guatemaltecos
hablaron sobre lo que esperan de los
próximos comicios Pues yo creo que la
votación es muy importante la verdad
Porque ahí sí que pues uno el granito
que puede dar es un gran avance para ahí
sí que para el pueblo verdad siento que
es importante que todos vayamos pero la
mayoría está en construcción la mayoría
la mayoría pero vamos a decidir todavía
a quién leamos el voto porque no hay
decisión todavía
tenemos que pensarlo analizar bien a
quién Vamos a darle el futuro a
Guatemala en Estados Unidos la Corte
Suprema del país se pronunció a favor
del gobierno de Joe biden en relación a
su nueva política de deportación de
migrantes por ocho votos a uno la corte
rechazó la impugnación de dos Fiscales
generales republicanos a esta política
que busca dar prioridad de deportación
algunos migrantes principalmente a los
detenidos en la frontera o a quienes
según El Ejecutivo representan amenaza
la seguridad nuestro corresponsal en
Washington Cristóbal Vázquez no se
amplía
con la decisión de la Corte Suprema el
servicio de inmigración y control de
aduanas Ice por sus siglas en inglés
podrá enfocar ahora sus esfuerzos de
deportación para aquellos inmigrantes
con condenas penales graves y aquellos
considerados una amenaza para la
seguridad nacional la corte determinó
que Texas y Luisiana que pedían cambiar
las pautas y las guías de la
administración de biden carecían de
argumentos para presentar la demanda
conocida formalmente como Estados Unidos
versus Texas en temas migratorios la
administración ha argumentado en la
subida de detención de inmigrantes que
hay debe concretar sus recursos
limitados y sus seis mil agentes de
deportación en la aprensión y
deportación de inmigrantes que
representan mayores amenazas para la
seguridad pública la seguridad nacional
y fronteriza los funcionarios de la
Administración han argumentado además
que la policía se basa en el
reconocimiento de que el gobierno no
puede simplemente seguir deportando
deportar las millones de personas que
viven ilegalmente en Estados Unidos esta
decisión de ocho magistrados contra uno
es una victoria para la administración
de biden y valida su poder para limitar
la aplicación de las leyes federales de
migración sin interferencia de demandas
legales
este sábado se cumple un año de la
derogación de la normativa Rover versus
wave por la que las mujeres de Estados
Unidos podían acceder a la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo de forma legal
desde entonces dos decenas de estado se
han prohibido este derecho y los grupos
conservadores y religiosos continúan
abogando por una mayor penalización del
aborto Marina sardinha con los detalles
un año de una decisión que suprimió los
derechos sexuales y reproductivos de las
mujeres estadounidenses el 24 de junio
de 2022 la Corte Suprema de mayoría
conservadora anuló la sentencia del caso
Row versus White de 1973 que permitía a
las mujeres abortar libre ilegalmente
desde entonces al menos 20 estados
tienen prohibiciones casi totales o
nuevas leyes que limitan el acceso a la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
debido a estas restricciones Amanda
residente de Texas estuvo a punto de
morir por un aborto involuntario
es exasperante y dicen que lo hacen
porque son provida Pero no entiendo que
tiene esto de provida porque estuve a
punto de morir porque están en riesgo
las vidas de mis futuros bebés
con la nueva normativa cientos de
clínicas tuvieron que cerrar el personal
sanitario y los médicos de atención
materna de los estados restrictivos se
enfrentan a la disyuntiva de renunciar a
sus trabajos o irse a los estados por
miedo a ser condenados
los riesgos de ser acusado de un delito
grave los riesgos reales de prisión y
cómo se vería eso para mi familia y para
mi carrera y todo lo que habíamos
trabajado tan duro para construir
con la prohibición vigente ya no pudimos
brindar el estándar de atención la
medicina más basada en evidencia para
ciertas complicaciones del embarazo
Porque se consideró ilegal
Pese a que las activistas defensoras de
derechos humanos han alertado que este
retroceso en materia de derechos pone en
riesgo la vida de miles de mujeres los
grupos religiosos y conservadores
republicanos aspiran a más y buscan
prohibir también los métodos
anticonceptivos la píldora abortiva o
los viajes entre Estados para abortar
por ello el viernes el presidente Joe
biden firmó una nueva orden ejecutiva
para proteger el acceso anticonceptivos
entre otras cosas Las aseguradoras
privadas deberán cubrir la mayoría de
los costos de estos medicamentos
en Chile Fuertes lluvias afectaron las
regiones Centro Sur y la capital del
país el fenómeno meteorológico que se
considera sin precedentes a la última
década ha dejado hasta el momento varios
cientos de evacuados las cifras
confirman que en las últimas horas han
caído unos 150 litros de agua por metro
cuadrado en dos días y medio las lluvias
han superado el total del pasado año
Rafael Pérez nos cuenta más
son las lluvias más intensas registradas
en Chile desde 1993 fuertes
precipitaciones fueron reportadas en el
centro sur del país y la capital
Santiago según el gobernador de la
región metropolitana los niveles fueron
los mismos que los reportados en el
transcurso del 2022 todo en Solo un día
y medio está lloviendo a 3.300 metros de
altura con lo cual se activa la quebrada
y Nosotros hemos señalado que este es el
peor sistema frontal que hemos tenido en
más de 10 años unas 359 personas fueron
evacuadas ante la crecida del río
mapocho que atraviesa la capital la
fuerte sequía que afectaba la nación
mantenía ese caudal en un 89% por debajo
de su nivel histórico del año 1986 que
el río no crecía de esa forma que nos
agarraba hace caudal y es impresionante
porque para la cantidad de agua si
ustedes se fija que hace dos días atrás
prácticamente el río venía vacío en el
centro y sur del país se presentó una
situación similar en la región de
Valparaíso el posible desborde del río
aconcagua mantiene a dos provincias en
alerta roja según la dirección
meteorológica chilena el causante de
estos eventos meteorológicos es el
fenómeno el niño un proceso natural que
aumenta la temperatura del mar Pacífico
y provoca un aumento de las lluvias en
varias naciones del continente americano
hasta aquí este repaso informativo sigan
con más en France 24
[Música]